voilà il ne s'agit plus de construire le
meilleur des mondes mais un monde
meilleur nous dit henri weber sa vie
illustre de manière emblématique
l'histoire récente de la gauche il est
le représentant d'une génération qui a
tout connu
les manifs la violence les jeunesses
communistes révolutionnaires et cette
conversion à la social démocratie alors
trahison ou bien retour à la raison et
puis eu les succès les échecs et
l'effacement du parti socialiste quel
héritage cette génération les stèles à
la gauche d'aujourd'hui ce sont quelques
unes des questions que nous allons nous
poser après ce film henri weber le rouge
et la rose de fabienne servan-schreiber
et patrick rotman et pour cela
j'accueille à présent david assouline
bonjour vous êtes sénateur socialiste de
paris vous avez un parcours qui peut
rappeler un peu celui d'henri weber vous
nous en direz plus vous avez milité à la
lcr avant de rejoindre le parti
socialiste avec nous également david
djaïz bonjour je essayiste enseignant à
sciences po
nous sommes également avec bruno cautrès
bonjour bonjour politologue et chercheur
au cevipof également enseignant à
sciences po et ludivine bantigny bonjour
bonjour vous êtes historienne maîtresse
de conférences à l'université de rouen
vous avez notamment écrit un article qui
a retenu notre attention sur le parcours
d'henri weber dans la revue contretemps
revue de critique communiste alors je le
disais est un film qui doit beaucoup
sinon tout à l'épousé d'henri weber
fabienne servan-schreiber david
assouline vous avez côtoyé henri weber
tête un homme aussi brillant
qu'attachant oui toujours souriant il
disait je préfère être pessimiste gains
optimisme
un optimiste triste et ça résume bien le
personnage parce que bien entendu il a
il a vécu les tragédies politiques mais
aussi des tragédies personnelles et il a
toujours été dans des convictions très
profondes n'ont pas été les mêmes
mais c'est bien par conviction qu'à
chaque fois il a agi et et puis là il
était tout le temps à se marrer
très très hâte à chaud on va parler de
ses convictions et de cette évolution
bruno cautrès je parlais d'itinéraires
d'itinéraires emblématique ce chemin
voilà de la révolution à la social
démocratie sont ils sont nombreux à
l'avoir fait dans sa génération
oui effectivement la trajectoire
politique d'henri weber est tout à fait
on va dire à la lumière de l'ensemble
d'une trajectoire d'une génération qui a
évolué on va dire au fil des mêmes
combats l'internationalisme la guerre
d'algérie mai 68
évidemment et puis évidemment le grand
moment de l'après 1980 et de l'entrée
progressive de cette génération aussi
dans les cercles du pouvoir est aux
côtés du parti socialiste puis à
l'intérieur du parti socialiste donc un
parcours personnel effectivement tout à
fait à l'image du parcours de toute une
génération tous n'ont pas suivi
exactement le même parcours qu'en khyber
mais nombreux quand même l'ont
accompagné david giles la tension entre
l'idéal et le réel vous qui avez la
trentaine c'est à dire à la jeune henri
weber au moment où il a commencé à
s'éloigner de la violence cette tension
elle est inévitable
je suis pas sûr que alors il a un peu
fait la castagne contre occident mais
henry n'était pas un homme violent et
même dans sa jeunesse il était
effectivement trotskiste et penser que
la révolution nécessité une action
violente mais moi je voudrais revenir à
ce que vous avez dit dans votre
lancement il a dit ça a été un acteur ou
un observateur de l'histoire de la
gauche moi je crois que c'est sûr ça a
été un acteur ou observateur de
l'histoire de la france et de l'histoire
du monde parce que il est quand même né
d'une famille de juifs polonais aux
confins de l'empiré soviétique
il est arrivé en france tout enfant au
moment où la france jeter dans la
reconstruction est inconnu effectivement
la guerre d'algérie mai 68 dont c'était
un de ces observateurs et acteurs
privilégiés de toute la seconde moitié
du 20e siècle et c'est pour ça que son
parcours est absolument émouvant et et
en même temps symbolique effectivement
de cette deuxième moitié du 20e siècle
mais lydwine bantigny je me tourne vers
vous qui est historienne dans le film on
l'entend dire
j'ai le sentiment d'avoir participé à
l'histoire de france il parle notamment
de mai 68 à ce moment là de fait il
n'exagère pas il a été un observateur et
la traversée et même participer à cette
histoire
oui absolument puisqu'il a été membre du
bureau politique de la jeunesse
communiste révolutionnaire de la ligue
communiste révolutionnaire il a dirigé
le journal rouge
il a aussi été un théoricien
révolutionnaire dans les années 68 70 il
a écrit plusieurs ouvrages et qui était
important pour l'époque notamment une
réflexion à chaussures 68 mai 68 une
répétition générale où il espérait
toujours une révolution qui suivrait 68
il a aussi beaucoup réfléchi avec la
pensée de trotsky à penser de rosa
luxembourg sur l'état la révolution il a
publié un livre qui s'appelait marxisme
et conscience de classe
donc c'était un théoricien un militant
et un dirigeant qui serait que la nette
de la culture révolutionnaire mois la
petite nuance que j'exprimerai malgré
tout avec ce qui a été dit par rapport à
cette génération c'est que à messieurs
il n'est pas forcément représentatif de
toute une génération c'est à dire qu'on
passe pas comme ça deux dirigeants
révolutionnaires un membre haut placé du
du bureau politique du secrétariat
national du parti socialiste
il a été directeur des études auprès du
premier de secrétaire atteindra il était
sénateur commandes c'est donc à elle
c'est pas absolument représentatif de
l'évolution de cette génération parce
que beaucoup ça ça a été bien démontré
aussi bien historiquement que
sociologiquement beaucoup de manques de
cette génération sont quant à eux restés
quand même fidèle à un espoir sinon de
révolution du moins de justice sociale
changement profond là il faudrait
revenir peut-être aussi sur ce qui dans
le film comme dans le débat peut
apparaître comme problématique sur la
définition de la social démocratie
je suis pas tout à fait sûr que le parti
socialiste des années 90 2000 soit 1
représentatif de la social-démocratie
1.2 vision que social libéralisme ce qui
évidemment est tout à fait différent
peut-être un point de désaccord sur ce
point là david assouline ps que vient
dire ludivine menti ni pas seulement à
laquelle c'est à dire que bleus
sur le symbole d'une génération et de
son itinéraire
moi je suis pas complètement de cette
génération puisque moi disons je vais
être un leader étudiant extérieur dans
les années 80 et c'est le mouvement de
86 et on disait à ce moment-là 68-68 ces
vieux 86 et mieux et pourquoi je dis ça
parce que ma génération a plutôt vécu le
fait que la génération de 68 mais pas
incarnée par henri weber voulais rester
l'éternel génération qui représente les
jeunes même quand il était devenu très
vieux est en général beaucoup de ceux
qui ont émergé dans cette génération ont
plutôt suivi des itinéraires de
dirigeants voire dirigeants
d'entreprises et non pas continuer du
tout sur les mêmes idéaux henry lui il
ya une continuité c'est à dire que il
s'est engagé avec des convictions il a
pensé comme moi quand j'étais jeune que
c'est par la révolution et par un
bouleversement général que cette société
pour vous pouvez être transformé pas du
tout par amour de la violence mais avec
des idées très généreuses de partage
d'égalité et c est un moment donné il a
pensé que c'était un impasse et qu'il
fallait pour arriver à cette société
d'égalité de justice
il fallait réformer la société passé et
discutant les principales exercice
démocratique nuitées il ya une
continuité mais de fait lui-même
reconnaissait qu'il ya une route à une
rupture au sens jeu je m'attends
d'ailleurs oui mais je ne dis pas qu'il
n'ya pas de queue qui a pas de rupture
il ya eu échange de points de vue sur la
façon d'arriver à cette société mais je
vois bien ce qui est dit
avant moi c est ce que quand on arrive à
la direction du parti socialiste est con
et sénateurs c'est qu'on a enterré tous
ses idéaux de jeunesse n'ont cessé c'est
pas comme ça c est et dans la génération
de 68
bien entendu il ya beaucoup
d'itinéraires différent mais ce qui
caractérise quand même ce qu'il a vécu
ce que j'ai vécu jusqu'à un certain
point c'est que pour moi il n'était pas
possible d'être un jeune qui a envie de
changer la société et être en cravate et
ne pas vouloir que les choses changent
radicalement je le conçois complètement
ensuite on peut considérer que ça passe
aussi par des compromis mais pas des
compromissions et henry n'a jamais fait
de compromission je vous pose la
question bruno cautrès une manière de
reformuler d'ailleurs ce que ce que nous
disait à l'instant david assouline
révolutionnaire à 20 ans réformiste à 40
c'est une une pente naturelle lui parce
qu'une fatalité
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose que
l'on dit souvent à propos de
l'engagement politique on commence ce
jeune assez à gauche et puis
progressivement on évolue vers le centre
vers le centre gauche alors comme
ludivine danthine il a dit tout à
l'heure c'est effectivement pas toute
cette génération qui a évolué dans ce
sens là mais c'est vrai que quand même
ils ont été nombreux parmi les cadres du
parti socialiste on peut penser toi tout
un tas de noms à ses célèbres de la vie
politique française qui ont suivi une
trajectoire qui si elle n'était pas
exactement la même que celle d'henri
weber lui ressembler quand même quand
même beaucoup c'est à dire étant passé
par
les différentes composantes de la gauche
radicale ou de l'extrême gauche et en
penser effectivement que la
transformation de la société ne pouvait
venir que d'un changement radical
en fait ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que ces trajectoires elles ont évolué au
sein d'une époque qui elle même a vu les
idéologies évoluer le rapport de la
gauche au pouvoir évoluer la pratique du
pouvoir par la gauche subir le on va
dire le feu de l'exercice du pouvoir et
donc une période aussi où il ya eu
beaucoup de beaucoup de transformations
c'est pas des individus qui évoluent en
dehors de transformation beaucoup plus
structurelle évidemment parler de
l'épreuve du pouvoir de l'exercice du
pouvoir ce qui évidemment ça a joué un
rôle aussi dans cette danse est
itinéraire peut être un mot un peu sur
l'itinéraire personnel d'henri weber
c'est bien racontée dans le film et
c'est une question pour vous ludivine
menti ni sa rencontre
son coup de foudre pour fabienne
servan-schreiber le fait d'entrer dans
une famille bourgeoise il le raconte lui
même
ça joue forcément un rôle dans le fait
que cet homme s'éloigne de l'idée
révolutionnaire ou bien est-ce que c'est
déconnecté
non je pense que vous avez en partie
raison les matches veut pas du tout
faire une analyse qui serait
psychosocial de la trajectoire dans les
débats il est certain que quand on
fréquente les milieux de la grande
bourgeoisie à laquelle ils s'étaient
opposés politiquement pendant toutes
n'ont pas seulement sa jeunesse mais
aussi une partie de la de la maturité de
sa trajectoire on évolue dont le regard
qu'on porte sur les rapports sociaux sur
les rapports de force au sein de la de
la société donc ça c'est une c'est une
évidence ce qui fait que ont fini par se
marier au fouquet's bon et ça je veux
revenir quand même parce que je sur la
question la génération j'entends
beaucoup parler d'une évolution qui
serait comme une pente naturelle pour
cette génération peut quand même se
rappeler que par exemple en 1968 c'est
une grève générale 1 et henri weber l'a
suffisamment souligné et analysé après y
avoir participé
il ya 10 millions de personnes qui
participent à cette grève générale
bon et donc sur ces 10 millions il y en
a quand même très très très peu qui
deviennent
sénateur du parti socialiste donc ça
c'est vraiment très important pour ne
pas avoir une image beaucoup trop pomme
homogénéisant d'une génération et je
pense que ça serait aussi dépossédé
cette génération de ce qu'elle a fait et
de ce qu'elle a fait ensuite et de ce
qu'elle a fait parfois jusqu'à
aujourd'hui tout le monde ne se
reconnaît pas dans la politique qui a
été menée à un certain moment par le
parti socialiste
et c'est pour ça que moi j'aurais aussi
une autre nuance parce que la notion de
génération mais sur la notion de
réformisme parce que là on dit beaucoup
il est passé de la révolution à la
réforme mais il me semble que en fait le
mot réforme il a il a toujours désigné
des avancées sociales en termes de
justice sociale on t'aime d'émancipation
en termes d'égalité mais quand on voit
les réformes qui ont été menées depuis
maintenant ont même plusieurs décennies
beaucoup les appels des contre réformes
parce que quand on met en cause le
système de retraite le code du travail
l'assurance chômage par exemple il
s'agit pas de réformes qui peuvent
apparaître comme progressiste donc je
pense que la rupture majeure s est
opérée par rapport à quelque chose qui a
toujours animé henry les nerfs comme un
certain nombre de ces de ceux qui
espéraient en la révolution ou dans une
réforme véritable du rapport au
capitalisme c'est justement le
capitalisme il était profondément anti
capitaliste pendant des années et des
années et en suit non seulement il a
estimé que finalement un compromis était
possible au sein du capitalisme mais
qu'il fallait aussi l'encourager c'est
le tournant qui est pas seulement celui
de 83 mais qui a commencé un peu avant
et qui ensuite a structuré la politique
menée alors il ya manifestement un point
de désaccord et ça va être très
intéressant d'entendre notamment david
assouline mais pas seulement sur ces
questions là je vous propose pour
avancer justement ce que tout ça a
quelque chose à voir avec la gauche au
pouvoir je le disais tout à l'heure à
l'épreuve du pouvoir et on va parler de
ça maintenant je juste avant le vrai
qu'on regarde ce passage c'est un moment
important du film un des moments clés de
la vie d'henri weber ce moment où il
raconte pourquoi comment ils renoncent à
la violence
l'idée qu' il fallait recourir à la
violence pour
transformer la société et c'est une idée
assez répandue j'ai renoncé en tous les
cas à la violence comme méthode d'action
mais ça c'est lourdes implications
canton renonce à la violence comme
méthode ça signifie qu'on choisit le
compromis comme méthode voilà le
compromis comme méthode
le mot a été utilisé à l'instant aussi
par ludivine menti ni il y avait
manifestement un point de désaccord
entre vous sur ces en tout cas sur ce
point là david assouline et puis après
vous donnant la parole non je veux dire
d'abord pour le point de départ il y
avait 10 millions de grévistes ont 68 et
il ya une petite minorité qui est devenu
sénateur socialiste est presque ridicule
parce que les 10 millions d'ouvriers je
pense qu'ils n'ont pas voté pour la il
sert ensuite ils ont voté pour les
socialistes pour qu'ils arrivent au
pouvoir
aujourd'hui on sait que c'est ça que
cette génération de 68 a permis à un
moment donné de faire qu'en 1980 il y
ait pas des contre réformes mais des
réformes qui peut-être pour mon
interlocutrice veulent pas dire grand
chose mais pour les ouvriers s'étaient
des gains de vie tout simplement
quand on a la retraite à 60 ans et que
en général quand on partait à 65 ans et
qu'on était mineur au mouret quelques
mois après c'était un bonheur absolu et
jeux et j'en passe non je vais pas aller
sur les réformes sociétales peine de
mort ou d'autres mais je parle bien du
social pour les ouvrir et quand on a eu
les 35 heures et quand on a eu la cmu
etc tout ça c'est la gauche et la
génération de henry et henry n'est pas
de ceux qui justement ont fait on
changer d'idée parce que il briguait ou
un marocain ministère avec le poids
qu'il avait au parti socialiste
remarquez qui n'a pas été ministre a
malgré le fait que des dizaines de sa
génération l'ont été avec moins de 10
ont de force et il n'a pas fait comme
beaucoup de sa génération qui avait des
talents incroyables
des affaires il n'a pas fait du pognon
aux qamoudi donc je veux pas qu'on cocon
ce qu on vulgarise ces itinéraires oui
il en gros c'est pas quelqu'un qui a
trahi son idéal
c'est quelqu'un qui a considéré qu'il y
avait d'autres chemins pour l'atteindre
et on peut le contester on peut dire que
non il s'est trompé la preuve que et
tout ça mais en tous les cas lui il n'a
justement quand il a bougé jusqu'à la
fin de sa vie il a jamais dit du mal de
sa propre jeunesse et de son propre
engagement il a jamais fustiger ceux là
comme les nouveaux convertis qui souvent
brûle ce qu'ils ont aimé la veille et ça
je veux lui rendre hommage aussi pour ça
c'est important de vous entendre là
dessus david djaïz parce que vous qui
est ambitieux né à la place qui est la
vôtre de régénérer elle-même
idéologiquement la politique aujourd'hui
quand vous regardez cet itinéraire et
que vous entendez comme dans le film
henri weber dire voilà ce qu'on n'a pas
pris nos désirs pour des réalités est ce
que finalement à un moment être
idéaliste c'est bien mais il ya un
moment où il faut exercer le pouvoir
vous êtes obligés de prendre tout ça en
compte qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
au fond été pris dans des forces qui
nous dépasse tous c'est à dire le
désenchantement d'un certain nombre
d'idéaux vous savez les années 60
c'est à la fois le climax de l'espérance
révolutionnaire 1968 effectivement
ludivine menti ni le disait 10 millions
de personnes qui débrayent au plus fort
du mois de mai mais c'est aussi le début
du désenchantement c'est le début de la
déchristianisation c'est le début du
reflux de l'influencé du parti
communiste donc c'est le début au fond
d'eux du désenchantement de ces grande
maîtrise collective en quelques sortes
et et très vite on va avoir la
génération fric l'individualisme le
néolibéralisme et ça c'est des forces en
quelque sorte qui nous dépasse tous et
donc je pense que de ce point de vue là
moi ce qui m'intéresse dans la
trajectoire d'henri weber c'est les
éléments de continuité par-delà
effectivement les changements
idéologiques qui sont liées aussi aux
époques
je crois que dans ces éléments de
continue de continuité c'est important
qu'on le dise il y à ce souci de
toujours lié la pensée et l'action
toujours terrorisé de toujours réfléchir
à ce qu'il faisait
et en même temps de ne pas être un
penseur hors sol que cloîtré dans son
université vous dites qu'il illustre en
tout cas des mouvements qui le dépassait
des mouvements historiques qui de toute
façon se serait produit ça certainement
mais au delà de ça c'est quelqu'un qui
en réalité avait une très haute idée de
la politique et voulait toujours penser
ce qu'il faisait contrairement à tant
d'autres politiques effectivement dont
certains ont été ministres huit
mini-jeux voir président qui n'ont
absolument aucune idée sur rien et qui
sont obsédés par la communication et de
ce point de vue c'était quelqu'un de
rare et bruno cautrès l'histoire de la
gauche tel qu'on est en train de de la
tracé au travers de cette cette figure
d'henri weber c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouve dans d'autres pays
évidemment ce mouvement qui mène à
l'exercice du pouvoir puis à la
désillusion c'est quelque chose qu'on
observe ailleurs oui bien sûr c'est
quelque chose qu'on a observés dans très
nombreuses démocraties l'évolution de ce
qu'on a appelé la social démocratie mais
aussi l'évolution du communisme en
europe
henri weber était extrêmement intéressé
par tout ce qu'ils avaient touché à ce
qu'on appelait à un moment donné leur
communisme les évolutions des partis
communistes italiens espagnols qu'ils
regardaient avec beaucoup d'attention
effectivement ce sont des évolutions
qu'on a vu dans l'ensemble delà de la
gauche des composants de la gauche dès
communisme en europe et des
social-démocraties en europe ça n'était
nullement ça n'est nullement un
phénomène français et je partage ce qui
vient d'être dit c'était au fond des
évolutions structurelles de nos sociétés
qui ont dépassé très largement les
témoins les acteurs politiques et ils se
sont ils se sont plutôt on va dire fondu
dans ce tableau adaptés ils ont essayé
de maintenir l'idéal de la
transformation et de la justice sociale
dans un monde qui était un monde en
train de s'ouvrir au fond le début des
années 80 effectivement le moment où la
gauche arrive au pouvoir en france c'est
plutôt le le point le point où on va
dire de cette trajectoire
et puis après c'est plutôt on va on va
plutôt vers quelque chose qui qui
transforme de l'exercice du pouvoir et
le rapport au pouvoir de la delà de la
gauche
on est à peu près à ce moment là au
moment où
l'interdépendance économique la
globalisation l'ouverture des marchés
les réalités d'une économie qui s'est
considérablement internationalisé
commence à s'imposer à tous les acteurs
économiques mais aussi les acteurs
politiques qui ont une nouvelle donne
entre les mains dont ils doivent faire
quelque chose parallèlement il ya les
progrès extrêmement important au même
moment de l'intégration européenne le
portage du projet d'intégration
européenne par la présidence de françois
mitterrand en particulier sur la
question européenne de ce que c'est vrai
que c'est important ce n'est pas
tellement abordés dans le film la
trajectoire d'henri weber c'est celle de
quelqu'un qui va qui va rejoindre ce
combat pro européen a piqué un moment
avec laurent fabius va dire stop au
moment du référendum de 2005 david
assouline
oui donc vous aussi j'ai fait ça mais sa
matrice très profonde jusqu'au bout
c'est que il
il misait tout sur l'europe et parce
qu'il avait une réflexion stratégique et
il voyait bien que dans le monde tel
qu'il allait les états continents à les
imposer leur loi et que voilà que
développer un projet disons harmonieux
alternatif à au modèle chinois au modèle
américain avec un certain nombre de
valeurs et de conquête qui existait en
europe nécessitait une europe forte le
plus intégré possible il s'est battu
bien sûr pour qu'elle soit sociale avec
le peu de succès qu'on a pu avoir dans
toute sa génération et la vienne
vous savez le trotskisme notre eau quand
on était jeunes on est élevée au biberon
de l'international
c'était vraiment une matrice très très
forte mais la grande question était
parti est soluble dans cette réunion
entre les cas ça ne l'a jamais quittée
c'est pas que l'union européenne c'est
la solidarité internationale c'est
l'attention portée aux et à
l'immigration et au dos aux droits des
ego des étrangers etc
il a toujours été là pas tellement dans
le compromis mais dans l'intro 10 ans
qui était nécessaire
même quand eux tous nos camarades ne
l'était pas autant je voudrais qu'on
avance après pour qu'on parle aussi de
l'avenir de l'avenir de cette gauche de
l'héritage killik éventuellement cette
génération laisse à la gauche
aujourd'hui
et pour cela ludivine danthine vrai
qu'on parle un tout petit peu de ce qui
est assez absent de ce film c'est à dire
les échecs les échecs de lunel jospin à
la présidentielle de 2002 l'échec de
françois hollande qui n'est pas en
mesure de se représenter
au fond on va pas faire un procès
évidemment ludivine menti ni mais met
sur le compte de quoi mettez-vous ses
échecs
est-ce que c'est justement cette console
compromis que d'aucuns y compris
d'ailleurs les classes ouvrières ont pu
considérer comme une compromission
oui mais je me permets du coup pour
répondre à votre question de dire que
c'est un mauvais message lancez donc
pour la qualité du lait des bacs de
dénigrer les propos d'autrui en disant
qu'ils sont ridicules puisque évidemment
ça je m'adresse à monsieur assouline a
évidemment qu'il s'agissait pas tout à
l'heure pour moi de parler des réformes
qui sont d'aller bien
la social-démocratie de vraies réformes
en 1980 c'est la suite c'est la suite
qui m'intéressait à cet égard à leur
rôle a dit le néolibéralisme de toute
façon c c'était une pente quasiment
naturel voilà on arrivait dans cette
période là mais dire que ça serait
naturel que ce serait une évidence ces
politiques qui ont été mises en place
aussi accéléré dans les années 90 et
qu'on a vu en corse ou françois hollande
elles correspondent un choix politique
on peut pas de nier qu'il ya un choix
politique il ya toujours des
alternatives possibles
donc je pense pour répondre à votre
question que la désillusion a été
immense et elle explique en grande
partie ces échecs électoraux aussi bien
de lionel jospin que de de france
parlant puisqu'il n'a pas pu se
représenter
on a parlé tout à l'heure de la violence
mais il faut pas négliger non plus la
question de la violence sociale
un certain nombre de mesures brutales
un pose justement au corps social et
notamment aux plus défavorisés
donc je pense que voilà cet immense
déception
elle est liée au fait que pour beaucoup
à cette politique finalement elle
n'était plus de gauche
alors qu'est ce qu'une mesure de gauche
c'est une question manifestement il ya
il ya des désaccords sur ce plateau il
ya une autre question qui est posée par
levine pourquoi nous sommes de gauche
c'était une question qui est posée par
les les enfants d'henri weber à leurs
pairs c'est l'un des moments
intéressants de ce film vrai qu'on le
regarde pour qu'on parle ensuite de
l'avenir et puis de l'héritage justement
de personnalités comme henri weber pour
la gauche d'aujourd'hui regarder sur le
ton de la conversation familiale vous
expliquez à vos deux filles ce qu'est la
gauche par rapport à la droite et la
droite par rapport à la gauche
d'abord est-ce qu'après donc ce après
cette conversation encore une fois sur
un ton très familial vos vos deux filles
sont maintenant résolument de gauche
aussi tout de suite après son passé à
droite
qu'est ce qui s'est passé elle était à
droite à gauche à la question quel m'ont
posé dans ce dans ce voyage mobile vers
ma bonne ville de dieppe s'est dit papa
pourquoi sommes-nous de gauche nous
avons été capables de transmettre à la
génération qui a suivi aux générations
qui ont suivi les valeurs qui étaient
les nôtres elles restent
fondamentalement attachés à la
démocratie ont valeur d'égalité aux
valeurs de liberté aux valeurs de
solidarité de fraternité
voilà deux deux petits extraits qu'on a
repris 1,2 de ce film qui illustre bien
ce qu henri weber souhaité transmettre
peut-être d'ailleurs fait-il preuve d'un
peu d'optimisme
david djaïz quand il dit nous avons
réussi nous avons réussi à transmettre
aux générations les valeurs et la foi en
la démocratie
d'abord je voudrais lui rendre hommage
aussi pour ça parce que on avait
beaucoup de points de désaccord et mais
on aimait en discuter longuement et
c'était quelqu'un qui aimait énormément
partagé en particulier vis-à-vis des
jeunes générations
c'est suffisamment rare dans cette
génération de soixante huitards qui a
coupé les liens avec la génération des
pères et des mères qui a un peu largué
les amarres et qui a eu du mal en
quelque sorte à se mettre dans une
posture de transmission pour être
soulignée ya très peu de grandes figures
comme ça moi j'en connais beaucoup
jeudi a eu beaucoup d'influencé 16 mai
sur
surtout pardonnez moi mais il ya très
peu de personnalités issues de mai 68
qui sont dans cette générosité cette
transmission vis-à-vis des générations
suivantes hier il ya eu un côté en 1968
dans chez certains leaders après moi le
déluge puisque individualiste aussi
totalement totalement et henri weber
c'était quelqu'un qui avait l'esprit de
famille à la fois parce qu'il était fort
était un formidable mari un formidable
père mais aussi quelqu'un qui avait cet
esprit voilà de partage de transmission
généreuse et ça c'est un créateur de
l'intelligence collective c'est
suffisamment rare pour être souligné sur
la question que vous posez je pense
qu'au fond il a il n'a pas eu de chance
mais comme beaucoup de gens qui ont
traversé cette cette deuxième moitié de
vingtième siècle parce qu'il a épousé
tour à tour deux grandes matrice
idéologique qui se sont effondrés l'une
après l'autre c'est à dire qu'au fond le
le le communisme révolutionnaire s'est
effondré mais mai 68 a constitué à la
fois l'apogée et puis le début d'un
déclin on a vu dans les années 1970 ce
que les différents mouvements
trotskistes maoïstes ces sont devenus
ils ont été réduits à la quasi
insignifiance et puis la social
démocratie au fond elle s'est un peu
embourbé et et je pense même que si on
regarde les choses avec les lunettes de
l'historien le cycle social démocrate
est terminée c'est à dire que cette
cette période qui va de 1945 à 2 à la
crise de 2008 peut-être on se disait il
faut réguler le capitalisme par des
mesures de remédiation de compensation
c'est ainsi qu'ils aient terminé nous
sommes aujourd'hui avec depuis le 11
septembre depuis la crise de 2008 de
prix à chris du coc vide dans un monde
qui est totalement différent et ce sont
de nouvelles matrice idéologique parce
qu'il en faut l'idéologie c'est une clé
de lecture du monde qui vont devoir
s'élaborer que la jeune génération va
devoir élaborer bruno cautrès et mené
très rapidement s'il vous plaît parce
qu'il nous reste plus que quelques
minutes mais dans ce que vient de dire
david giles le cycle de la
social-démocratie est terminé pourtant
pourtant la gauche et le parti
socialiste continue de gagner des
élections
en tout cas localement comme on l'a vu
récemment oui effectivement ça montre
que les clivages politiques le clivage
entre la gauche et la droite ce sont des
constructions mentales des visions du
monde des manières de penser le monde
qui sont incroyablement résistante et
résiliente on n'abat pas un clivage
politique par une victoire électorale
et c'est vrai que ce sont des sondés
façon se représenter le monde qu'ils se
sont construite progressivement sur des
décennies vraiment d'aider utilisant
pour rebâtir un projet politique qui
nationalement pourrait convaincre
alors ce qui est vraiment intéressant
c'est qu'on voit qu'au niveau des
valeurs politiques qui continuent
d'exister des visions très contrastées
effectivement ceux qui pensent qu'on
peut transformer le monde qu'on peut
réparer les injustices de la vie et
qu'on peut le faire en redistribuant
mieux les richesses sont des profils
politiques et idéologiques très
différents de ceux qui pensent que et
bien il faut faire avec
qu'il faut accepter le monde tel qu'il
est et pour moi c'est un peu ça la
grosse différence entre la culture
politique delà de la gauche et de la
droite donc ça continue d'exister
alors est-ce que c'est suffisant de
réactiver cela pour ressourcer pour
redynamiser pour faire renaître un
projet qui soit un projet de gauche
unissant les différentes composantes de
la gauche parce que c'est une des
difficultés aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui
il manque sans aucun doute quelque chose
qui soit de l'ordre de de l'étincelle
d'une personnalité qui a le talent qu a
la possibilité de parler aux différentes
composantes de la gauche et ça c'est une
condition absolument sinéquanone d'une
victoire électorale mais il n'y a pas de
raison de penser que ça ne puisse pas
arriver quelques secondes de réaction
ludivine menti ni au fond le problème de
la gauche aujourd'hui serait t'il comme
le dit un temps bruno cautrès plus une
question de personnalité qu'une question
d'idéologie certainement pas
certainement pas ma c'est vrai que j'ai
pas cette conception qu'on entend ici de
la personnalisation du rapport à la
chose politique
comme quand on entend que en 68 voilà
les leaders sont devenus individualistes
était là voilà encore une fois ce sont
des millions de personnes et c'est
pareil pour les forces politiques
aujourd'hui avec le candidat du parti
socialiste à la dernière élection
présidentielle
justement il a fait un score
relativement insignifiant pour reprendre
la formule qui a été utilisé ça montre
que c'est pas une question de
personnalité c'est vraiment une question
de projet et quand on perçoit plus non
une force émancipatrice dents
dans un projet d'un parti où on trouve
aussi bien un benoît hamon qu'un manuel
valls voilà il faut il faut considérer
que ce parti n'a plus d'âme et ablement
lieu d'être et ne peut plus forcément se
situer comme si ça allait de soi à la
gauche de l'échiquier politique à la
gauche de l'échiquier politique il ya
d'autres forces
à la question qui auront un autre essor
et il faut en prendre acte aussi ont
vaillamment les désaccords il va pas
relancer le débat maintenant mais david
assouline un mot de conclusion parce
qu'on a commencé par enlever père faut
finir par henri weber et peut-être dire
c'est de votre point de vue c'est quand
même votre point de vue sur l'avenir de
la gauche et du parti
mais précisément j'allais vous vous
posez la question de la manière suivante
henri weber aujourd'hui pour le parti
socialiste et pour son avenir
reste-t-il à vos yeux un exemple ou un
un contre exemple autrement dit voilà en
quoi peut-il aujourd'hui vous aider vous
qui souhaitez que le parti socialiste
est un avenir
et s'il vous plaît rapidement je vais
faire le lien avec eux la question vous
avez posé avant quand même parce que
justement encore vadam le parti
socialiste aujourd'hui n'a ni manuel
valls et benoît hamon son ca il y à des
militants par dizaines de milliers qui
ont décidé en 2010 est de reconstruire
et de continuer cette histoire du parti
de jaurès avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'abnégation et de conviction en partant
effectivement d'un champ presque de
ruines et tout le monde à gauche
à notre gauche et à droite on prédit
disparition d'harriet remarquer qu'on
n'a pas disparu et vous allez le
remarquer aussi dans cette élection
centrale où les forces politiques
doivent s'affirmer et donner une
perspective au pays avec la
présidentielle que ce ne sera pas le cas
et il y à des passeurs pour cela et on
est en fait henri weber jeu parce qu'il
faut conclure sur lui c'est ça a été ça
et je pense que c'est ce type de général
de dirigeants politiques dont on a
besoin aujourd'hui qu'ils transmettent
une histoire qui nous dépasse et
l'histoire du socialisme
elle nous dépasse et elle a bouleversé
ce pays dans le sens de l'égalité du
progrès et c'est avec cet espace
politique que les transformations
continueront et la régulation f
aujourd'hui du capitalisme et la lutte
pour l'égalité la solidarité c'est pas
derrière nous il a pris des nouvelles
formes d'exploitation mais voilà il y en
a qui ont dit ni de gauche ni de droite
et ces élections comme les prochaines
montreront que ce clivage il est bien
encore là merci beaucoup merci david
assouline merci à tous les quatre il ya
eu des désaccords qui se sont exprimés
et c'est très bien je renvoie à d'autres
vos livres ludivine menti ni révolution
paru aux éditions anne à mozac et puis
ce titre que j'aime beaucoup 1968 du
grand soir en petit matin paru au seuil
en 2018 je renvoie aussi à votre ouvrage
slow démocratie david giles et puis
aussi à ce manifeste pour une échelle
humaine que vous signez david giles avec
le collectif des 40 c paru aux éditions
bouquin il y a quelques semaines merci à
toutes et à tous de votre fidélité à
public sénat
[Musique]